marketing for the now
marketing for the now marketing for the
now marketing for the now
10 minutes 12 remarkable guests
for two hours answering a singular
important question happy birthday
to you happy birthday
to you happy birthday
happy birthday happy birthday to
you
guys happy happy 45th gary
thank you andrea we know it's not your
style to be the guest on your own
show but it's your birthday and i guess
you're giving us
a gift today so thank you for that thank
you for having us i
know the murmurings have been going on
in the virtual halls
i'm eating a tomato and radishes by the
way radishes are you're gonna need it
you better yeah you better like stefa
because we we have not
the 12 guests with the singular
conversation today but we actually have
more than
33 guests for five minute conversation
so we gotta go we gotta jump in right
now okay
are you ready i'm ready all right let's
go so
first up we have an entrepreneur you're
younger
a numbers guy and your brother
what's up everybody the perfect person
to start with what's up bro
what's up bro happy birthday times too
thank you my man
so i guess i have to do this is a funny
format uh
aj what's a good story or
an insight you know obviously you know
me the most
and um what's something building
vaynermedia
that i told you that doesn't get talked
about like what's a what's a secret
business that you know i want to bring
yeah i gotta go yeah yeah
i got a good one um i've recently just
had this conversation
maybe yesterday and i kind of don't
think i've ever brought it up in any
other podcast or conversation so i think
it's a good one
um i would say that in my early 20s
getting into my professional career with
you starting vaynermedia
i was i was fairly rigid as an
entrepreneur i was somebody that i think
had years of scholastic kind of
experience drilled into me and i think i
relied
and was overly rigid on things i think
something you and i have talked about
before was that
i've changed my opinion which is kind of
ironic i've changed my opinion on the
concept of changing your mind
it used to bother me if you said
something on a monday and then you
changed your mind by friday i thought
that lack of consistency was
mind numbing but i think in my late 20s
and my 30s
i've softened my rigidness and i think
for the better and i think
entrepreneurship
you need to sure balance is great
moderation is great but
i think that's something that you really
helped me with because i don't think
anybody would call you rigid
and i think it's something that you
exposed me to you spent the time and
energy to talk me through it you could
have easily just brushed me away and
said like i don't have time for this
conversation
especially given how fast we were
building this thing but
i think that's something that i took
that was very valuable for me and i take
pride in my
you know i still have rigid tendencies i
think it's part of my dna but i think
i've definitely softened those things up
over the last 10 plus years what do you
think the biggest misconception is
now that people know who i am that you
know that you think everybody's got a
different take on
your actual willingness to operate i
think probably there is
a uh an assumption that's made that you
wouldn't want to spend the time on
staffing or organizational shifts or
strategy planning like that you're too
go go go out in the open i don't think
people realize that if i
you know at one point in vayner in 2012
i said hey gee we need to like lock
ourselves in a room with like one or two
other people for six hours and map this
[ __ ] out
that you're game for that i think people
would just assume that you would
want other people to figure that out and
take care of it i think just far more
operational willing and minded than
people realize
what's your favorite win over me
i think that's easy it comes immediately
to mind and i think you already know the
answer
don't tell me no no actually i wasn't
gonna go there that's probably my second
favorite
um i think beating you in basketball for
the first time
at mom and dad's house one-on-one
basketball i think i was 17.
i like literally ran off the court with
my arms in the air right to the kitchen
to tell everybody in our family that i'd
finally beaten you just because
the way uh your style of mentorship and
guidance was to
make me earn it i never beat i didn't
beat dairy and basketball until 17 years
old um there was no fake wins
none of that absolutely i just lost
every single time you played back walk
about 17.
and i i think honestly i think that's a
great thing and i take pleasure and i
think it was a good thing to shape me
tell them number two because it's an
all-time one number two quickly because
i think we're bringing in our next group
of guests
uh i was what gary seven or eight nine
one man nhl 94 i came back from college
i think so i would say it was
not 94 you were seven or just twitter
yeah seven or eight
i beat gary in a video game for the
first time we played angel 94
i beat him his immediate reaction was he
punched a hole
in my childhood bedroom wall and left
i love you bro we'll move on i love you
too i think i'm sticking around actually
oh good
but i'm also i don't know how there we
go oh
the main is that's me
that's you dude that's mom i'm afraid
i'm not going to get my five minutes
because i love you all right
i'm going quiet i'm kicking it to the
crew i'm hanging out but i'm quiet
mom you need to get in here because
let's be honest people have seen liz
and dad enough on instagram nobody ever
sees you
the most perfect time for me to come out
but i'm not moving he's not forgiving me
[Laughter]
i love you guys liz how you doing
selling any homes i'm working on it
liz what's the biggest thing that you
wish you listened to me earlier about
everything everything
it's so upsetting i'm halfway through
and i'm like damn it i should have
listened from day one
it would be so much easier dad when did
you first know i had it when i came to
the store
is that the question yeah it's a
question no no
it's supposed to tell the story
what i learned i got a story okay
knowing you you've probably been
thinking rehearsing this yeah
[Music]
she's making a reference to your
speeches when you
like at weddings you bring up something
you watch at two o'clock in the morning
tell your story tell your story dad and
take a lot of time
guys you're going to love it trust me
so i don't remember how many years ago
but at the wine library
gary had a meeting and he
had a lot of meetings with staff or
whatever but this one
stand out so we're sitting in the
meeting
and gary i don't remember exactly
wait wait dad before before you get
going can mom get in the camera i want
to tell you
yeah one second let me at least get mom
stay mom stay one second
okay all right thank you i just wanted a
screen shot this is a fun little okay
so anyway so uh uh i don't remember a
hepa dozen management
i don't remember exactly who i think
brandon was there
i'm not sure but uh anyway so
gary conducts this meeting and
basically i'm going to try to be short
whatever
they it was you know 40 minutes meeting
whatever an hour whatever but
and basically gary tells all his
managers
right management team he tells them what
basically basically he's going to fire
them
i swear to them no we know this story
keep going keep going he's gonna fire
him with what
he did he's going to fire every single
one of them
right and i'm sitting there and
everybody
was you know smart kind of very
comfortable whatever
basically the guys live in my office
right
and they're all pumped and they're all
happy
and i'm sitting there i'm stunned okay
i'm saying to myself this [ __ ] excuse
me my language guys go and be fired
and say walking out of my watches pumped
happy right
and i'm saying if i were sitting there
and i will tell
every single one of them guys we get a
10 000
race that would not be as happy
as the situation what gary just
basically i i'm still to this day
fascinated by what real took a place
at that day and and i said to myself
it's like gary said recently uh
about a different uh subject it's all
about delivery
it matters that's matters i mean
my delivery sucks i know that but
there's a it's there's a great quote
maya
angelou i think it's people are not
going to remember what you say but
they're going to remember how you made
them feel or something that extent
that's right that's absolutely it yeah
that's because that meeting dad
i i was giving them kind candor which is
something i'm trying to get better at
but in that moment i was able to use it
because i didn't want it to be bad for
them
i didn't want it to be bad for them i
just told them the reality
the business was not in a position right
at that point for them to be able to you
know
that's the x-men and that's uh you know
what i was advised not to
say but i i can't help myself
[Laughter]
uh what's his name george
george right get him out i mean he's out
right
if george is out if his deliverer was
different i don't know how sir
wholesaling will play
liberty matters
[Music]
intent
andrea i'm going to give you the best
career advice of all time i would get
off the screen right now
i'm giving you good advice this is the
best advice better than the [ __ ] i told
me
i just wanted to say i'm gonna i'm gonna
throw a birthday party for sasha and
tomorrow
that's right september 10th is my dad's
birthday we'll have a three-hour show
longer than my show
go ahead liz brown yes dad you're done
but i'm like i feel so lucky
that you're my big bro
that you have always loved me
unconditionally
and when i see my own children
have a similar relationship to us i feel
like i need to say
sorry and that i
love you and i think the biggest gift
you gave me is your unconditional love
you love me
good or bad brave or or
fearful and i love you
happy birthday thank you you're my best
big bro
happy birthday love you honey come on
mom real quick
hold on hold on family mom yes can i see
you i'm looking at this yes
mom why don't we start prepping our
new york times best-selling book
perfectly parented
the book the book the book that is going
to make you more money than dad's made
in his entire career
okay i'm out love you dad
amazing so i can't tell you how many
people were
fired up to see your mom we got so many
i didn't want to tell her in advance
because i thought you may get too
nervous
we're so thrilled finally get us this
here so next up we have
a serial builder of e-commerce companies
one of the most influential in sports a
philanthropist
and the creator of the all-in challenge
michael rubin
wow reuben
what's up gary vee happy belated
birthday brother thank you so much
brother how are you
i can't hear a word you're saying but um
hopefully you're gonna get some sound
here
and i can actually not only hear your um
can you hear me so you're pretty
baseball to hear your voice can you hear
me
not yet yes now can you hear me
not yet but listen i can't hear you but
here's what i'm going to tell you
first i want to wish you the happiest
bladed birthday in the planet
second i want to tell you i was just
thinking about um
i was just thinking about everything
that
i've been through with you in the last
year and what's amazing for me
is you know when we first came up with
the all-in challenge idea together
i was thinking that like we had no idea
whether this was gonna work
like no idea whatsoever but you know
what you know
we all just went in and said [ __ ] it
we're gonna we're gonna create a great
outcome for people who are hungry
and you just went all in and just worked
your ass off to do the impossible
and that's why i love you so much
because you never quit you don't ever
give up
you just find a way to will [ __ ] to
happen and that's who you are and you
know when i was thinking about your
birthday i was actually i don't reflect
on my birthday
but i was reflected on your birthday i
was thinking the thing i love about
garyvee so much
is he never ever ever quits you just
always find a way to persevere
and make things happen thank you brother
can you hear me right now yeah
awesome beautiful um exactly who's here
is going to find a way to make my
computer
i don't think that that's going to be
delayed
that's right i can figure out the delay
listen how i'm going to work on sign
language it's got to be this one exactly
listen i'm we're gonna work on signing
listen most importantly
let's let's do head shakes do you feel
old
no because you're a young stud you will
everything to happen
um and you're the best and listen most
importantly i really
just want to wish you the happiest
birthday here you know let's see if we
take this off
michael first of all thank you so much
while michael's trying to get his stuff
together
no worries i can't hear you now um
i admire this dude so much a real
executor
does a ton of good the social justice
advocate is exactly right what he's done
with prison reform
his he is the the ideator of the all-in
challenge
there are very few people on earth that
match
my energy levels my ambition levels
my just sheer will to make something
happen levels
and it's been one of the great
advancements of friendships during this
time
for me in this last you know five years
our
relationship has advanced but so much
and when i think about 2020 i will
absolutely know that that was
one that one of the things i'll think
about is that it's the year that michael
and i became closer
i admire you brother thank you for
coming in for this and give me five
minutes good luck with your off season
for the sixers you guys are making moves
i see that and
i will see you soon
love you bro so gary next up we've got
high school bestie
og of wine library all right dention of
the family brandon warnke
can you hear him again i can boy i love
you so much literally when they just
said that i literally
brandon tell them what i randomly texted
you today just literally out of the blue
what on the on the piano no not on the
wine we sold today on wine text everyone
signed up for winetext.com
no just the didn't i was that i mean all
these days blurred together hold on
am i wrong oh you oh earlier when you
said you just loved me so much
yes that's how i feel about you
i i love you with all my heart happy
birthday for those of you don't know
i've known gary for over 30 years i met
on my first day of high school
and for me he's taught me
more things than i can ever possibly
count but one of the biggest things is
always do what you love no matter what
and you know
a real quick kind of side note to that
gary and i went to the 2014 or 15
baseball hall of fame inductions because
we wanted to go and see frank thomas and
greg maddox
kind of get inducted we planned the
whole weekend out we went up and when we
got there
we actually didn't go to the induction
because we found
that there was a 50 mile trek of garage
sales
going on in the town maybe 20 or 30
minutes away and so instead of going to
the induction
we went garage saleing all day literally
and it was amazing we had a great time
well we were left i mean like aj said
earlier always be willing to change your
mind
always we said that we were going to go
to see frank thomas go into the hall of
fame
for 20 years we go up to cooperstown
we find out at like 11 p.m that saturday
night
that there's this garage sale and we
literally [ __ ] changed our entire
plan
and had a great time brandon what was
give everybody the first business
interaction outside of like the name
and not the story of the names in the
homeroom but like literally the next
thing that happened in our friendship
in september 1990 the first
full conversation we had got it well i'm
gonna blow you away
because you have no idea i mean it's
really kind of ironic
um gary and i met for baseball cards and
one of the first things we did was we
did a deal where gary gave me some
hensley mueller cards
hencely mullins was a
gary i actually got this no
this is an autograph this is the card
right here and it's autographed
i sold brandon this card like several of
them
literally within the first conversation
that we ever had with each other in high
school
well and we got one other big baseball
guy coming up right now
on the line i believe he's here brandon
before we
we transition from a business standpoint
the biggest thing that you think people
can learn because i want to bring value
here instead of just a gloat fest for me
what like what stands out as like
something that you think people can get
value from of like because you know me i
think
i think i spend a lot of time thinking
and analyzing and your biggest thing is
it's important obviously but just do
just go just put things in prospects and
go
try different things check them things
and that's something that has been a
real hard challenge for me
but i am continuing to try and do every
day
go go go go faster go faster don't be
perfect because it won't be perfect
um but you get so much tremendous
knowledge about
how it works and what happens just do
just do stuff just do
i love it love you bro love you guys
the most i wonder where the special
guest is there um
you know we just a matte cinnamon or
wanted to jump in on the tales of prince
there we go matt vitimer hey gary happy
birthday
thank you brother matt you were the only
employee that worked at wine library and
then came over
to vaynermedia nate nate was an intern
yep um matt this is fun for me because
you've been on the west coast holding
[ __ ] down we haven't had as much chance
to interact so actually
like with everybody else so far i kind
of know where they would go
what what's a good story what's a story
you tell when people know we're
connected this deeply
or what's a good learning like i really
want to bring value to the audience so
what what what what can you add what's
like to me the the less cliche things
or like or is there a story that
capsulizes something or
something that can bring value thoughts
one i wanted to share one of the first
things you asked me to do when i was
when i was your assistant um matt was my
first assistant and i really didn't know
how to use one but i knew i needed one
so the to matt's credit one of the great
meetings in my life
was matt coming to me matt how many
a month in three weeks two months in
help me when you came to me and said hey
[ __ ]
you need to learn how to use me and i
give you a ton of credit for that
because it's not so easy to go to that
person and say hey you know
i don't know how early that was or or
tell your story because i want to hear
it because i have no clue what you're
about to say
you trained me and i trained you but
yeah one of the first things that we
that we did together was to personally
email 5 000 wine library customers about
chateau grand main 1999
is that true which you know probably oh
it's so crazy
about that what year was that it's like
13 years ago
right so what i talk about personally
hitting people up on dm
or replying to comments like this is
something i'm talking about 13 years ago
everybody
that's it that's it i think it worked
right because i remember we saw the [ __ ]
load of chat programming yeah well we
had a lot of it to sell yeah we did i
was scared of shitless i'm like matt we
gotta
text everyone oh andrea but we're
failing the unscalable
it was about the power of
personalization which we do today
it was about like understanding
attention and not taking it for granted
and the fact that we couldn't just do
the same thing over and over again
me and brad i bought seven thousand
cases of pinot grigio so me and bran are
figuring that out right now it's deja vu
it's the best ratio of all time by the
way everyone should buy it all right
andrew go ahead matt i love you
love you too and i banned it
man i'm telling you that's at least a
thousand dollars on ebay once i get done
with my next 20 years so keep that safe
priceless to me i love you brother love
you too thanks guys
next we've got one of your south by
southwest buddies
an early client a c-suite extraordinaire
and someone who's beloved by
beth comstock hi gary hi andrea how are
you
beth happy birthday thank you have you
been
good i know how you've been i keep up i
try to keep up with you it's impossible
to totally keep
up with you but happy birthday beth
thank you so much
beth and linda both and paul markham
deserve a ton of credit
what a big bet your organization made on
vaynermedia in 2009 when
it wasn't as obvious it wasn't clear
thank you for that
i'm so glad i get to thank you for that
here in this public domain
well thank you the work was amazing in
fact that's one of the memory the
earliest memories i have i think we met
up in the early days at south by
southwest i
became a ritual where we met there sort
of every year in austin
but i just i never forget our first
breakfast there
and um i i had known you before i think
we may have even worked a little bit
together but what i love about what you
do is you you lay out your vision
and there at first you're like well wait
a minute is this guy kind of crazy
like he there's no way he's gonna do all
this
and then i was able over the years to
see every year
yep checked he did that i think when we
first met i don't even know if you had
100 employees
no um i saw you go from like one floor
to two to three to this huge office with
thousands of people
uh you'd you'd say things like you know
okay we're we're gonna do it better than
the traditional ad guys we're gonna get
into advertising mark my words and
i'd be like that is so hard next year
there you were
there you were doing it we're gonna
start a speaker's bureau there you were
doing it so
i think one of the things i i learned a
lot about
um certainly not just your hustle
obviously you you are the king of hustle
um but you're loyal you're loyal to
people
you're loyal to an idea you're loyal to
your team
and that those people want to help you
because they know that
but i think you learned a lot about just
putting a bold vision out there
and saying to people almost kind of like
prove me wrong prove me wrong
and but yet there's something very
infectious about it that you find i
don't want to prove it wrong i want to
help you i want to be part of that i
want to join in that
so that would be a gary vee lesson i was
fortunate to learn
and and i guess i would add great work
the work was really good
beth i wanna i'm just gonna enjoy giving
you a little shout out from a leadership
and mentoring people's standpoint but
what i really love about you is
the curiosity that you maintain
i think it has been a major strength of
yours through your career
i you know whether it was in the work
whether
we were talking about new apps that were
popping at south by whether it's when
you embarked
on your book i i love humility
uh you're much more graceful than i am
it's harder to see my humility unless
you get closer in
but your humility is a real superpower
of yours and i think it's something a
lot of people watching right now could
learn
and uh i admire you and i always have it
thank you and it's not even my birthday
thank you it's great to see you what
what's next gary well i want to hold you
all i wanna
i wanna i wanna
how can we help you what's next
you know what's so funny underestimating
me is the thing that most helps me so my
friends and loved ones
struggle with that because they go the
other way especially the way they get to
know me
but what's next i i'm gonna say
something right now and i've never i've
not said it that much publicly but i'm
trying to make this fun
i think i will be a dominant force in
movies and television
the ott television of the future i think
my next two decades
i will spend a lot of time in original
programming
in those formats and i'm excited about
that i see that the way
i saw 12 years ago when you and i talked
about where i was taking this in madison
avenue
and i'm excited about that well i i have
no doubt you
i have i can't doubt it at all uh and
uh i hope you'll have the jets with you
when you do that too that's definitely
gonna happen that thank you so much
but this next one she is a unilever vet
a badass boss lady with mile
are you destined are you guessing i know
exactly who it is
happy birthday gary thank you how are
you
i'm good i'm good you know it was so
funny when
um they asked me what story i wanted to
tell
i mean there were so many and some might
get you in trouble like when you ate
off my husband's plate i'm glad your
parents i don't know if they're still
watching
every literally anyone who's ever had
dinner with me knows
i mean i am the most anti-covered human
on earth i only want to hug
i only want a high five i only want to
eat off people's plates
yes that is gary gary well i never told
you was that he had chewed the piece
that you then ate
gail what i'm saying what i will tell
you right now is the lack of fear that i
have of that
it's like you can't imagine you can't
imagine
how not skeeved-out i am when it comes
to anything
okay well then there was a story of
inviting you to unilever
and i i don't think the anglo-dutch men
in suits had seen someone drop as many
f-bombs in about 90 seconds
that you did and and still let us hire
you
so that was another one but i think you
know when i think about you
you know look a lot of people see sort
of the gary that's
that's all over the place and i think
what's really important
to know is there's the power of network
which you obviously have
but there's the power of connection
which i think
is your gift and your gift to connect
with
all different types of people and the
caring and the sincerity that just comes
through so i just have to read this
because um i found this email
from july 1st 2013. so this is seven
years ago
okay okay the headline is omg
two of my favorite people in the world
you must meet
gary claude is the coolest smartest
chick i know
she currently lives in london working
for some fancy agency on the p
g business boo it's she's moving back to
the states
she needs a kick-ass job can you
brainstorm with her
claude gary is by far the coolest guy
i know google him but of course you know
him
but he's even better in person please
connect
and i think that day
and you guys met and it was like i knew
you
i felt what you needed i knew her the
second you guys met and so that
power of connection um and just
two people i don't know you're both so
down to earth you're both so caring
you're both
so brilliant and i'm so happy that you
found each other
because then i got to stay in the
picture this is true everybody this
incredible
extraordinary winning human
of a juggernaut gail is the individual
that introduced
claude our chief heart officer that so
many of you know
to me and they've been best friends
since
birth three four what is earth moms
right
and um we share so many
tendencies gail which makes me love you
because i have a lot of self-love
and they appreciate you and i i i
i rip i would love to get that email
because i'd love to frame it and put in
my office i love you for that i love you
for
everything that you are thank you so
much have a wonderful
birthday love you thank you gail
that's so cool you know it's beautiful i
think we're gonna
we need we should have sent you a bunch
of kleenex gary yeah brandon always gets
me
all right the next one new york times
best-selling author
speaker entrepreneur and
founder and ceo of pencils of promise
adam braun
adam hey gary hey brother how are you
oh man i'm doing well i'm doing well i
like this
yeah yeah i'm out in the mountains um so
i figured i'd like
tell everybody how we physically met
because i think it's one of the great
stories that
would be fun is that where you were
gonna go 100 when
when your team reached out first of all
obviously i text you about it but
happy birthday you know i love you with
my heart and um
i'm just so grateful to to have you in
my life um
and when when the team said hey if you
can share one story
about gary um i immediately told them
it's a no-brainer it's the night we've
met so um
you know i haven't showed this many
times before but uh a good mutual friend
uh matt hiltzek said you know you and
your brother you gotta meet this guy
gary
um you know you're really going to hit
it off and and most of all you're both
jets fans so obviously i had to
yeah we're a little jets
um and so you know we we meet up at
nice restaurant in midtown um you know i
have to wait a little bit to get seated
we sit down
you know four of us are you know having
a great conversation
aj joined that's right that's right
that's right
it was a brother get together all around
so um
five of us are there having a great meal
just diving in you know talking life
family values
you know the the whole kind of nine and
uh i would say within maybe 20 minutes
if i you know i'm guessing uh of us
sitting down
no no no no no no adam this is good news
i have a big time memory
okay but i love what you just did so
there
we're there the table's not ready so we
it was uh nobu in midtown so it had that
outside area
so we've got to go back outside right we
knew we had to wait 20 minutes
yeah we go immediately into jets
football we're fully in jets football
because we just went to the afc
championship game
yeah yeah it was a great year where we
just went to the game before the super
bowl we're all talking about the
excitement for the following year
and literally we're sitting there and up
and walks into the restaurant i'll let
you take over uh starting quarterback
for the new york jets mark sanchez
and we lose our [ __ ] minds yeah can't
believe it
and and not only that but then the
seating is that he
is the table over basically like my
back behind me and so i mean we're
talking
you know life football everything but
obviously mark sanchez is right there
you know all these diehard jets fans
kind of geeking out and uh
you know this was part of what they
asked is like you know share a story
that has a lesson related to gary and
i remember almost without hesitation
like you just went over
introduced yourself started a
conversation next thing you know
his crew has combined table
with a crew you're talking to him about
the reads that he missed
and you know he he was like
off on and he's correcting you and
you're like no no no no let me tell you
what actually happened
and it ended up being just you know an
all-time epic night an incredible way to
start off
you know a friendship that's really
become a brotherhood
and um you know it was just like that
that fearlessness
um but the authenticity of like this is
my passion this is my love and this is
someone that i wanted to
dive in with that um that i just
remember so so well
um it was an incredible incredible uh
incredible night incredible memory
the the second very quick one is when i
taught you
about um potentially joining at the time
the pencil promise advisory board
because i remember you you know started
to gain interest in it you and i had
started to get close
and at that point in time people that
had the schedule that you had the
success you've had
you know usually we kind of slotted them
into advisory board which meant that
they didn't really have to devote much
time but they became a meaningful donor
and you know had kind of the bad phone
to call me anytime and get engaged to
the extent that they want and i remember
you saying to me look
um i think we were on like park avenue
probably 18th like one of those coffee
shops around there and
and you said to me if i'm going to do
this i'm going to go all in i've never
been on a board of a non-profit before
but
i really love what you're building you
know i believe in you i believe in this
organization
and uh you took the leap and you know
pence of promise would not be the
organization that it is today without
you the impact that you've had on
you know children and and families
around the world is just extraordinary i
know it's not something that
um you know most people uh necessarily
know you for but
i think that it's something that um even
though you don't
you know kind of puff out your chest
necessarily about that side
of your life all the time it's it's the
part of you that i think that i've been
so um amazed and enamored and just um so
grateful for
and i want to make sure on a day like
today that that you get the the
recognition
that you deserve for um for all that
you've done for so many
i love you a lot brother thank you dad
everybody else
i will the last thing i'm going to share
with you is this little guy right here
he hand signed you man signed by cook
yep by by uh original illustrator
and thanks to gary i rekindled my love
of cards and today is actually my twin's
birthday
and this is what i'm going to be gifting
to my son part of my childhood i love
that
that's awesome happy birthday brother
adam don't distract him with those
trading cards because the show's going
to be entirely over and we've got a next
guess
he was your first client meets professor
guest shark and vice chairman for the
miami dolphins
matt higgins maddie what's up gary
look at that look you're right over my
shoulder too do you see yourself you and
aj
yes that was so fun one of the literally
one of my top
three highlights of covet going fishing
with you and aj a couple months ago
thank you for
pushing us i love you for that how are
you this is great it's kind of like your
birthday meets your wake right because
yeah exactly i mean
everybody you give the roses to people
while they're alive i like this formula
exactly well well for those of you out
there haven't heard the story
i i used to oversee the business
operations of the new york
jets right and uh jeff fernandez of the
jets who's our top sales guy was like
you got to go see this guy
in springfield new jersey he's got a ton
of money and he wants to buy the jets
and you got to go sell him the sweet i'm
like
i google him like this guy ain't buying
sweet and i don't think he's got a ton
of money yet
so but i do the right thing i go to meet
gary for a a cup of coffee
at the bagel store what's the name of
that bagel place carrick bagels bagel's
for you
bagel's for you right we sit down and i
really don't want to be doing this and i
remember the first 10 minutes i'm
listening to gary
gesticulate about you know this is how
the world is going
social media is going to be huge this is
2009. and he's saying how every this is
completely legit
every single person is going to become a
combination of comcast
and hbo right they're going to be
they're going to be the pipe and they're
going to be the content creator
because of the smartphone and me my
little brother aj he's still in college
but when he graduates
we're going to launch a firm and it's
going to be huge we're going to change
the world because all these
corporations are are are like battleship
carriers and they're not going to be
able to manage their social in this
world they're going to need to rely on
outside agencies because they won't be
nimble enough right and i remember
first 10 minutes i was you know whatever
second 10 minutes like wow gary does see
the future
and this guy like wow imagine i could
just steal all his good ideas i could
make an entire career out of just
emulating them
professionally and otherwise and i was
like first i'll steal as good ideas of
the new york jets to look like the guy
who gets it
and i'll generate features about myself
one of them is hanging in gary's
uh wall which i give him zero credit for
me being so dynamic
and then i'll just and then he'll tell
me all the good things to invest in and
then i'll do that too
and then i'll tell the world about my
great track record so that's been our
relationship for a decade
we cut a deal where we nailed it four
jets tickets
to become first client and the
conversation was let's take one player
who probably doesn't deserve to be that
famous or is not on that trajectory we
took a safety right
kerry rhodes and we had wine at uh that
place in summit i'm forgetting
for delhi fidelity and we cut a deal and
gary went ahead and started creating a
content machine and carrie did great and
so
i had the honor of being uh the first
client and then ultimately became gary's
partner
so you know what i love about gary is
that
uh you know we all struggle with being
self-possessed and really believing in
ourselves and
and what i love about him is everything
you see that you put out there is
legitimate
the thing i admire the most about you is
how how uh humane you are
and how unapologetic you are for being
that kind of person
and how you are unshakeable in your
faith in yourself but in others
and so if there's one area of my life
that even at 46 i'm disappointed i have
not been able to emulate i've stolen all
your best ideas
but i haven't been able to steer your
attitude yet but i'm working on it
carrie
as does everybody else who follows you
you're a little sweetheart
like i love you happy birthday please
don't ever die i'm glad this is in the
wake i'm glad this is the birthday
i'm trying i love you pal thank you so
much i i can't explain
the brotherhood that we have and i'm so
proud of you and thank you for seeing it
then and
i love being in your corner and you and
mine and um
i just don't like the dolphin's success
right now i think you and mr ross and
the rest of the
miami people might have figured it out
and while my team still has no wins
it does look that way but i'm not going
to i'm not going to rub that into
another day tomorrow
thank you matt thank you now we've got
some ogs of the most og
of vayner what would the world possibly
do with
marcus
guys sam i love you so much i miss you
brother where are you
i'm in switzerland right now actually i
love you everyone i was in turkey
yesterday
sam and my brother aj met freshman year
of college playing basketball time sam
transferred to usc but their
early sophomore year right sam but their
friendship stayed
and sam would and sam and zang who zhang
and marcus are both still
at vayner major players zhang a dominant
player in media
kudos to me pulling him on the side and
saying i think you should be in this
department
and marcus is my right hand and my chief
of staff
but they're both still here the reason
sam got the biggest ovation is
i miss him i haven't seen him in a while
men
talk you know a lot of people don't this
is a good moment
this is a good moment i'll tell you why
a lot of people don't believe my stories
people don't believe me
i don't know what to say people don't
believe that at 34
i didn't have the financial ability you
know we started
our company at a buddy media conference
room
all three of you were the interns that i
refer to
if you started in a conference room
at buddy media i'm getting i don't want
to verify
i want to i want to know funny stories
about buddy media
like and and the context was i wasn't
there a lot because i still had a ton of
wine library responsibilities i was
barely there even for the first year and
a half
anything that people there's actually i
want to stick here for a second
um what did you learn about those days
that being good all of you were better
students than me
what did you learn in being true in true
entrepreneurship
that you don't think you would have
believed if you never had that
experience
of the [ __ ] dirt that we ate together
yeah i mean that was one of the things
we were talking about uh
is i think people would be surprised how
much the vision of the company changed
in the first two years
um and how often we were bouncing around
between different ideas and one of the
things we were talking about
patient panda hello
um network yeah
yep at lunch karl motes um
and uh and and basically we were talking
also about um
wait saying what was it called again the
things we used to do every week that was
like almost like coming up with new
ideas for the company
share and tell so like literally like
every week we would have like meetings
with the full company which is like
eight people and like would talk about
like news new technologies like come up
with like basically like mini business
ideas that we would then like kind of
like spin out and try to turn into
things
um so like the the social media like
community management aspect of it was
really like
25 percent of like what we were doing in
the first like really we did we had
taiwan tech talk
we ran an event um that matt cinema
actually basically
managed front to back think about who
was that benefit and like went on to do
what yeah
yeah travis calendar dave morin uh uh
and then rose the guy who did uh soccer
yeah
so uh basically and then really wasn't
even until two or three years in when it
was like oh okay like this is the thing
like okay now we're gonna like rally
around yeah sam what was the biggest
thing
what was the what what is your biggest
thing that you kind of you know you knew
of me for four years what was something
you learned or something that uh young
professionals or entrepreneurs can learn
from like what like something like
what's a hot take i mean i think just to
be adaptive and not to be
precious about anything you know we just
kind of
every day we were constantly
experimenting and constantly
just trying something new and asking
each other questions and involving the
team
and i mean the fact that we changed so
much was maybe uncomfortable for some
people but i
that was kind of what i loved the most
about it you know and it prepared me for
life too like i
change is the only constant really and
um
you know that was uncomfortable in the
beginning
but you have to adapt to what you know
what's happening around you
and sam you know i'm trying to bring
value here
as the company grew up we were so close
and i was starting to make decisions for
300 people
not for 30 person companies i remember a
lot of those things
you were either i don't want to use a
word for you
perplexed disagreed with i'm trying to
think of how to bring some value here
like
in that transition and now looking back
now watching it all play out
what did you learn disagree with
now in heights i'd agree with in the
game of like making tough decisions
because i had to make the ultimate
decision of a growing thing
yeah i mean one of the things is like
vayner in the beginning and the first
few years always like family first and
that's what we talked about you know and
eventually
like you have to also understand that
you're not just a family or a business
and i
for sure i got mad at you about a lot of
things you know but i think
obviously understanding that you know
like
there's it's more than just family and
you have to also kind of evolve with
people it can be both you know but you
have to also make a differentiation
at a certain point and that was tough
for me to grasp but um
you know we did it zang i i knew you was
such a great leader what did you learn
in that first year to like just being
such a 22 year youngster i mean
you have a ton of natural kind skill
sets or things that nature but anything
stand out of
what you learned to become the leader
you are now in those early days
i i was actually going to say one thing
that i observed from you gary was just
how you when you made a decision to make
a change it wasn't an incremental change
it would go
and basically take it to as far as the
extreme as you can
physically or economically afford to
take it and then
see if there's an impact and if if
there's if there is if there's progress
then you kind of lean further into it
and kind of like the the i guess like
the quick decision making of like going
all in
if you have a hunch and and kind of like
the trip
the the incremental changes are rarely
going to lead to the outcome
that you're hoping for marcus what's the
biggest change you've seen in me so
you've been uncomfortably close to me
over the last three four five years
biggest change
that might be a good learning experience
in some ways for somebody
yeah i mean i think you're much more um
strategic and i think considerate of
like the way you interact with people
and like the way that like uh i think
you manage other people like i think
that like early on even probably
when i first kind of came into like
offices ceo first and then chief of
staff
like you know i think very much so
everything was around you
right and i think it was the company
itself was a very much sort of a
manifestation of like kind of like the
energy that you brought in the way that
you like to run things and i think over
the last three years
um obviously you still bring a lot of
that and bring that strategically but
there's also an understanding of other
people's
skill sets personality types the way
that they like to interact with things
and and
you just becoming more and more
considerate of that um
is definitely a big piece that's changed
i love the oh geez love you guys
gary i still want to know who was the
first employee but we're going to figure
that out later big debate between zhang
and
and sam and only aj really knows because
it was paperwork and logistics and it
was
hardcore all right we'll get to the
bottom of that later because next we
have
ebay power user at 13 forbes 30 under 30
and founder of mcmack
rachel tipograph
i'm sorry you were thinking about what
other ebay power user do i know
other than health rach thank you for
being here
as you know and it's it brings me joy
based on my reaction you are truly one
of my favorite entrepreneurs in the
world
and thank you for doing this how are you
worries good happy birthday
well i'm so proud to tell the world uh
how much you mean to me and i've spoken
about this publicly
but uh you know you invested in mcmac
six years ago uh you were the first
check-in outside of my parents
and when you wrote the first check
because we'll get to the second check
you told me that i was going to learn
one big lesson
do you remember what the lesson was uh
no the lesson was patience
you told me that it takes five years to
build a real business
so five years from the time that you
wrote the first check
i hit around four million in revenue
and you know now we're a year past that
i'm on year six
and the company is going to be at 15
million in revenue
and your initial investment is over 10x
its initial value
and you were only the only people who
ever believed in me so that was the
first
check the second check was a much harder
moment
and that was a year and a half into your
first investment where i realized i
needed to change the business model
and it was summer 2016
and i tried to go out and market and
raise money
i actually got a term sheet and then
that investor pulled it for me
and i was so desperate and i remember
spending the whole weekend
sort of living in fear and then i worked
up the courage to call you
and i told you what happened and i said
these are the three reasons why i
believe i need to change the business
model
and this is the one reason why i think
you need to reinvest in the company
and you said i need to talk to my cfo
but you have my word
that i'm going to help you and 24 hours
later you called me and you told me that
you could reinvest in the company and if
you didn't do that
mcmac would not be where it is today
you um i believe in you and always have
i really think you're an incredibly
talented woman
who i just knew looked like me
in a different form and would go through
those you know you were this great
executive
at gap and other places and i just knew
that once you calibrated what this game
actually was
that you would be a huge winner and it's
been a great joy in my
life to be such a supporter of you yeah
i'm so grateful
oh that's it that's it all right rach i
love you i love you so much you're right
i'm here to be andrea today so
that's hope that's right
next up we've got a 40 under 40 winner
serving the
who's who of brands from samsung to hulu
to tick tock nick tran
my man oh yeah what's good bro you know
just celebrating your birthday just like
you helped me celebrate my birthday last
week with my life
super fun yeah good to see you bro i
love it um i have a fun story to share
that's not business related actually
this is
one of the first dinners we had i don't
know if you remember
we went to uh hunt and fish club in new
york
it was like 10 30 at night and it was
one of those first interactions that we
had where we were just starting to get
to know each other which i thought was
really cool
we obviously like hit it off but you
definitely um
shot me a note saying like hey i'm free
at 10 30 you want to meet at this place
i walked in and it looked like one of
those scenes from a movie where you
expect to like see setting
your like congress people or you know
whoever who's who
in life and as we walked in i noticed a
bunch of people kept stopping you
on the way back to the table saying like
oh garyvee and they wanted to shake your
hand and you were
ridiculously gracious and you stopped by
and you actually like
hung out with each person that
recognized you and you spent time with
them so i
first it made me realize how grounded
someone could be
even if they're that you know well-known
and popular and all that fun stuff
anyway we get to the back of the table
and they bring out the menu you ordered
like a seafood tower or whatever
you like ordered and uh the the
manager came out and he just like you
know mr mr vaynerchuk we're so happy
that you're here
everything's on us we're gonna take care
of the full bill we'll take care of
everything
and i remember without me thinking i
literally blurted out to you i said like
that's kind of messed up and you were
like what are you talking about do you
remember this at all or no
i don't which is funny because i
remember most [ __ ] so i'm like literally
riveted because i'm excited to see like
i don't know the answer to this test so
i'm like what the [ __ ] going to say
so then uh i i literally told you
without thinking
and this is obviously early in our
relationship and i said you're the last
person that needs a free meal
of everyone in this restaurant you're
probably the last person and yet they
gave it to you which is kind of [ __ ]
up and then you literally said
you're right and that moment of like
clarity where you were just like
i'm taking this feedback i'm accepting
it and you told me that's why i'm gonna
give the staff
like a huge tip and you literally gave
the staff a huge tip
and you showed me two things one you
were just like humble about taking that
that feedback but two
you're extremely generous and empathetic
and you recognize that the people there
that needed it the most were the servers
and you gave back to them in a big way
which i was just like this guy
is genuine and he's real and i can't
wait to have him to be you know a bigger
part of my life
and since then we've done a bunch of
stuff together we're now doing cards
which i
promised andre i wouldn't talk about but
i brought it up anyways
14 seconds on when i first told you you
need to get into cards because i think
it's a ridiculous story because
it was so early and it was so not on
anyone's radar so i'm just dying to
get your perspective of how you took
that in yeah no i mean
we told this story once before but it
was literally a breakfast that we had
we obviously together in l.a and then
you said i have an idea that's going to
melt your face off
you had me hooked it was like the best
opening line ever i'm going to use that
line
yeah moving on but you told me to go buy
luca
and i remember going on ebay that day
and luca was going for
35 for a ps810 so i started buying a few
of them up
and before we knew it you know a year
and a half later they're going for
1500 or whatever the number is so
and the happiness the happiness oh my
god that's what matters the most like
the camaraderie that we have now with a
bunch of
dudes that are just like loving cards in
this text chain that goes off every
single day
about like what's going on with sports
and life and culture and everything it's
amazing so
obviously thank you more for bringing me
into that world all the all the
people that have boards all the people
that um
are building empires you need to know
this man one of my favorite marketers in
the world it's so fun to have reach and
nick you know i'm of the age now where
i'm not the whiz kid
i'm in a place where i can see the whiz
kids coming up and nick i've admired
your work
at taco bell i loved meeting you at ces
for two seconds
i now recall the the hunt and fish but i
recall so many other things i
i think you're going to have a hall of
fame marketing career and your hall of
fame
good person and i i'm really glad you
came here thank you so much
of course happy birthday love you all
right thanks nick
gary next up we've got another serial
entrepreneur that seems to be a theme
here
master of the company flip and just a
good buddy
michael lazaro oh
were you listening to the buddy media
conference room story i
was i loved it two things came to mind
which i hadn't thought about one is that
i think
i could be responsible for vaynermedia
in two ways we gave you the start but a
year into it you came to me and you said
laz buy this from me for five million
dollars
it's true that part has never been told
you've told kind of starting funny media
you came to me and said buy this from me
for five million dollars
yep and you remember what i said
no i said this is your future
look at the i love it listen no i said
this is your future
aj you need to you need to put your head
down and build it
and you know without vaynermedia there's
no vayner
yeah that's just right 100 you know it's
funny
it's a story i got to talk to aj about
telling the story it was a story
predicated on aj really
not wanting to do it and that was hard
and at that point i wasn't able to do it
100 and that
and you're absolutely right and then and
then when that happened
it was oh there's aj this story is true
i guess that's aj vayner sports
um oh he is i'm stuck yeah and and that
was a
we talk you know what's funny about that
story me and aj
when we when i realized aj was serious
he didn't want to do it anymore
and i was like [ __ ] i'm not ready to run
it we're like we got to do this with
flash because we believe in last so much
i'm still not sure if we wouldn't have
made more money selling it to you
because you [ __ ]
are a gangster and sold your company for
uncomfortable amounts of money
what you were doing was such a hard
business
at the time that there was no way i was
gonna do it and
so the fact that you wanted to get out
of it was absolutely
the right move the fact you were in it
i'm like
why are these guys doing this business
like it's like client by client by
client
at a time when social media was
hot but the money was not big right
if you got a 20 000 deal it was like
we're going to sizzle right
now it's kind of like there's so much
money in social media
but you know for us i think what you
know i love seeing you fight with cass
i love your kind of relationship where
you go at each other
but you know some of my best memories
are really just family time
you know your dad playing ping pong with
miles
in turks and caicos and i didn't think
both of them were going to leave the
room if they was
they were heated going after each other
and i think miles was three what about
when i tried to pay off your kids to
become jets fans
well that i mean that's been well told
and it's got millions of you
millions of views that was amazing um
but you know really you you care
you set a great example and you know
looking back over the way too many years
that we've been friends
i couldn't imagine doing buddy media
without you
and really turning to you and keep times
of my life
so thank you for everything um i love
i love the texts which are i haven't
seen you forever
we have to get together for dinner
there's nothing more important
are you free tuesday at 11 30 p.m
no i'm asleep i'm asleep at 11 30 what
if it's that important 11
30 if that's the squad i don't know 30
is my main that's my main slot
that's right the rest of us
need sleep so happy birthday love you
love you you are absolutely one of my
favorite entrepreneurs everybody in my
community that's deep knows my
admiration for you i look up to you i
love you
i'll see you soon okay see ya
at the 11 30. so true that's what
makes it funny all right andrea thank
you for this thank you to you and
everybody at vayner this is a
epic i didn't know the details so this
is exciting
hey it's been it's it's been one of the
the greatest thing is the outtakes and
all the side stories we're gonna have to
do another show about that later i love
it
i love it all right so next up we've got
another og vayner
um he people is his hobby he's an
entertainer with a big heart
robert souza oh the seuss
what's up baby what's up my guy i am
good i'm sitting here in the
the studio a at uh irvington plaza
in uh west chester and i'm loving to be
here so glad
yeah robert i'm gonna i'm gonna jump in
i apologize because i actually think you
can bring a ton of value to a lot of
people that follow me
and i have a very specific question
you you were an incredible you know
executive in the fashion industry in
canada which led to you being early with
relationships with people like john
legend and just
other like you know sizzle a lot of
things you know a lot of people with a
lot of notoriety
what's the most unique difference of how
i play it
that you've observed because i think you
have a very interesting point of view on
this
and it's something that i'm not sure
what you're gonna say but i'm excited
because i think it might help people
who are starting to command more
followers
more awareness and i think you know i'm
just i'm just so
curious actually to the the way i've
navigated
in your eyes versus the other 8 000
people that i know you know that all
navigated in my opinion
in a more similar way though i don't
know the answer to the question of like
what you've observed that's different
and i think it might help
some people right now so that's why i
went there does that make sense 100
uh and it's a lot of thought that that
i think about all the time by the way so
it's easy for me to answer uh i hope i
do a decent job of it for you
uh i mean listen first for them honestly
for everybody so first and foremost um
i i spent 20 years in luxury fashion
with hugo boss and valentino yes
i work with uh the four seasons to john
legend to
you name it armani and all these folks
and and
and at 2000 at 46
44 i joined vaynermedia uh with with
gary at uh running vayner live
um i was 44 uh which makes me 50 today
and
and i never had a mentor in fashion that
was
younger than me by the way i still have
not had a mentor that was younger than
me
so to actually leave vayner two years
later still working with you
and and have a mentor that's five years
younger than me was amazing and why is
that because
you really showed me a different
perspective than anything i've ever seen
in the way you do business as you talk
about so my
my learning by the way because i was
asked to have something to bring to the
table
for your fans was your approach to
efficiency
and time and execution and i can tell
you you already know this because you
have
thousands of creatives in your world
fashion's all about romanticism as you
called it and creatives
we could talk about the color blue for
another hour or two hours
about what you know what was our
spiritual you know
inspiration around the collection around
the song we wrote
and we can go on and it's great to do it
but i learned
you can do that with 10 more people a
day if you just got more efficient and
i'll never i'll never forget some of the
the first meetings at vayner when
i was used to like going into a room for
an hour and people told me in seven
minutes where the meeting was done and
i had to leave what what is this place i
don't understand it
and and dude it took me a long time to
understand by the way it may have been
rightful the second year
until i understood the idea i still
didn't understand it actually but now i
do because
you and i have something in common we we
probably love to meet every person in
the world
and i still try to uh i do it over
drinks you do it over calls and
meetings and all that stuff but i got to
tell you
i actually was incentivized by learning
that i can get as much done in in 10
minutes that i used to do in an hour
and it's important to get to know people
but you also taught me something by
saying
in the beginning of the meeting after
the the quick rub
and the quick icebreaker you know hey
how can i help you
and what we also share in common is the
idea that you have to give first man
like you have to give what can i help
you with
who's not going to be open-minded to
that conversation
and it was authentic if you don't have
authenticity
then none of it really goes anywhere so
i will tell you that
execution is number two getting it done
that's what i love to do i'm not a big
you know you saw
you saw me struggling with you you
actually once said to me
it pains me to watch you in a board room
looking at
documents with clients it just pains me
because exactly
i am leveling you your imagination your
magic in your element
and this is what i'm trying to get
everybody michael roche uh
bar slate ashley snow daniel clark all
the people in the chat right now if
you're watching please comment on what
stream you're watching
because i'm watching i want people to be
put in a position to succeed
yeah and that's why it's why it's why i
wanted you to build susan associates
and you nailed it and by the way it took
me 46
years and someone five years younger me
that's not even in luxury that's not in
my industry and to tell me hey man this
is what you do
and and you talked about it on various
shows about
you know being you not being someone
else you said it on an episode i don't
know what it was but
you talked about maybe the 4ds where you
said hey man
you know what you have to actually not
worry about people judging you
to be able to be efficient and to use
time wisely if people judge you for it
then you're gonna have too many problems
trying to figure out
what's the right thing to do and you'll
never win anyways thank you man
love you bro happy birthday love the
show thank you
thank you robert next up
you ready gary you need a pause luke
said you got to look at the text so i'm
gonna i'm gonna remind you that just
it's it's all good but not now because
we've got
rapper singer songwriter tara whack
hero whack cherowak is she here
georgia is she here uh oh
i know we got a lot of people in that
backstage room so maybe we've got a
little bit oh she just left us
all right i think she's going to come
back on
and so maybe what we do georgia let's
hear from
stephanie mcmahon
gary i am so sorry that i can't be there
in person
uh but i did want to make sure i
recorded a video for you
um late night yacht parties and can
aside i think one of the things that we
really have in common
and where you really touch my soul
is in the love and respect that you
clearly have for your father
and the way that you speak about him um
the the way that you
light up you know when you talk about
him i think that uh
that's something that that really
resonates to me and it's not necessarily
a lesson learned i think it's something
important that we should all share
because love and respect is what brings
us all together
and i just have to say thank you for
bringing this world together
in so many different ways with your
leadership your entrepreneurship
your community everything that you do
and
you know i look forward to the next
party on the yacht so happy birthday
gary
i can't wait to see you
i love that you know being a you know i
couldn't agree with her more
like admiration for pops is a real thing
and i know
she has it and obviously i love
wrestling so much so that was super
awesome thanks steph
and thanks andrea for this continued
epic day
all right we going yeah we got some more
folks that are going to come in
uh it's your college gang let's see who
what whoa
let's [ __ ] go let's go
happy birthday to the building let's
[ __ ] oh my god what's up g
what's up what's up drock miz what's
good
moose you good oh my god
happy birthday my brother what's up l.a
dustin what's up man
oh this is [ __ ] amazing three on one
is the [ __ ] scratch
right 301 maybe 301 twice in one day
gary
i know glenn oh my god it's so great to
[ __ ] see you guys what's good
what do you got moose moose tell them
how i told you how to hustle
uh that that might take too long
yeah i don't have that much time and
when i tell the story of how we got up
super early in [ __ ] college to go to
toys r us that was my story
don't cut it get it glenn take it you
tell it all right so
we we're glenn don't know how to use
this type stuff
graham get off real quick go ahead glenn
i'm on mute no you're good go glen so
freshman year in college we all just
click right away
we're it's a friday night
is there room for joe here there's
always room for tokyo joe baby
there's been a lot of successful people
on this today
a lot of special people on here we
thought we would bring it down a little
bit
we want to level the playing field for
the rest of the folk yo real quick
everybody this middle man the real
handsome one iraq that's the [ __ ] guy
when i tell the story
when i got the interception in the game
this is the man that came out running
out and pulled a [ __ ]
baseball bat out of his [ __ ] pants
let's go
baby
go ahead glenn all right so we're
drinking it's a
big friday night probably first second
with the college
daddy morning it's about 7 30 8 o'clock
and there's gary hey anybody want to
take me to toys r us
we're all hungover i'm like toys r us is
he kidding me
i'm like what the hell is he going to
toys r us for we're in college
it's true everybody knows this is my
[ __ ] true [ __ ] family i love you
fellas so much
what stories we got mousse
[Music]
what about when we went to foxwoods we
would drive four hours to go to foxwoods
and then in the casino for nine minutes
and ago
it took longer to get gas than the
amount of time in the casino
you could talk about warren's face after
that loss
this is a real story tell this is a real
story all these guys and i
on a saturday morning the knicks are
playing the pacers
here's the lesson it's never [ __ ]
till it's over
the all the fellas here we're watching
nick's pacers unfortunately joe here is
a pacers fan
but but you were emerging then joe
because i don't remember
dude my camera and audio is going insane
right now well that's because glenn is
breaking the whole [ __ ] thing
why am i all these guys i didn't break
the internet did i
no you didn't break it glenn anyway the
story is
very simple everybody left to go play
basketball i said i'm watching the end
of the game
and it was the reggie miller game and
when i went outside and told him the
knicks lost
not a single [ __ ] person believe me i
know you remember that l.a because your
[ __ ] face when i told you that you
were stunned
and you were crying how about how about
how you broke every hole
and put a hole in every single wall when
the jets played
and i don't know man what's good baby
i made it home tell them about the bar
evil
you're [ __ ] everybody up
hey we got too many stories we got way
too much
love too much camaraderie
too many good times too many bad times g
[Music]
man you've been looking pretty you got
to say something
[Laughter]
oh this is the [ __ ] best
joe don't worry we're going to make this
a podcast because we got to tell the
story about when glenn jumped over the
thing like
we got to do an [ __ ] i had a good
story
you got no joe you got the mic
i mean honestly i can hear myself from
30 seconds ago talking
yeah i promise you just talk okay i
can't i don't
i'm not gonna do the story but i will
drop a couple of things
so gary i mean everyone knows gary is
this ultra successful businessman
and i know gary as a guy that would eat
the big
toes the big toes toenail for five
dollars
we didn't even need the five dollars
[Laughter]
the man would not lose a bet no matter
what it was
[Laughter]
let me enjoy it for a second
we're
mumbling about some [ __ ] he sound like a
[ __ ] rapper right now
i don't know what the [ __ ] he's saying
back there bad appeal for life baby
matter [ __ ] people
give him a contract
[Laughter]
i'm no i'm the new post malone
my stories are x-rated okay so you're
out
i love you man happy birthday i love you
happy birthday g
i love you fellas we'll figure this out
miss i love you that was exciting
i've ever been
[Music]
all the fake social media people out
there this is real
not none of that fake [ __ ]
thanks so much you guys 301 baby
301 happy birthday man thank you miss i
love you
and there are even more of them gary we
just couldn't fit them all in the
backstage
those were the ones those were the right
ones oh my gosh my face hurts but
we got a comedian coming on next he's a
comedian
writer emmy award winner hassan minaj
how am i going to follow a dude who
pulled a bat out of his jeans
i'm just saying i'm in a i'm going to
say this before you say anything
in the history of my in the history of
my life
one of the most flattering things that
have ever happened to me is when i had
you on
my podcast i have such immense
admiration for your talent and your
humanity
and you came on that show and you
started dropping so
many nuances of the things that i've
been saying for the last five years
that i don't know if anybody like to say
like unless you have a photographic
memory i was like my god this guy
really knows my content like the most
super super
super fans that i've ever come across it
was humbling
it meant the world to me i've never
really really told you like
how much it pierced me and i'll never
forget it to the day i died
it meant so much to me bro i came in
like it was my snl audition like i'm
like this is my gary vaynerchuk like i
knew
like you know what i'm saying um no i'm
bro happy birthday man i just wanted to
come in and show love man
thank you brother bro you're you're
actually now on some sort of
what what are you in the second season
of because i watched the first season
the morning show the morning show dude
i'm a dramatic actor bro bro i'm fired
up i mean i watched the whole first
season and now that you're in i'm like
wait yo it is straight soap opera status
man but it's dope
it's really dope how you been listen man
i just gotta say thank you man for being
an inspiration
like even your proof
that immigrant kids with add can go the
distance so that means like
it means so much to me even when they go
to college with those kind of [ __ ]
characters totally totally but also man
what you did with the sneaker deal
inspired me to start doing problems
like shout out to you i saw that this
morning a lot of people but a lot of
people don't know like i was like hey
gary was the one of the first people
that kind of put me on to that of like
you know like a non-athlete we can we
can do this
you know what i mean so shout outs to
you bro being a vanguard being a
visionary
uh i can't wait to like have proper
dinner i can't wait talk about somebody
i can't wait to hug congrats on all your
success
thank you [ __ ] started man i admire
you a lot for your
sweetness your sweet [ __ ] dude thank
you bro appreciate that
you busted my balls though when we hung
out where you're like what was your gpa
well
you took the gpa thing to a whole nother
level as if i wasn't like
a hustler too you know what it is it's
it's
the same thing you just saw with my
buddies like i have i have
instant forever friendship with you so
you go into that fun rag mode you know
what i mean
i don't even mean it i was just having
fun happy to be with you so
uh all right bro thank you so much happy
birthday thank you bro
peace thanks hassan
so gary take a breath next up we've got
investment banker
philanthropist with a huge heart and a
badass chairman and ceo
of aqui hope tates oh
hope how are you you can't
what's happening with your audio you
can't hear me
no i can't i can hear you perfectly hi
hope
hi gary happy birthday thank you hey
listen
i'm the only person in the finance world
that you had me
sit outside your office for a half an
hour to wait to be
interviewed to go on the pencils of
promise board
okay i sat there okay and you made me
wait for a half an hour
okay and i'm like who the hell is this
guy
okay and how lucky am i to have gotten
to know you
you're right one of my great friends i
love you so much i admire you so much i
want the whole
you know how much i want the whole world
to know you because i think you bring
so much value thank you for being here
so
but you bring so much value what
everybody knows is about the gary that
hustles
and everything but that what they don't
know is that the gary but has the
biggest heart in the world
the gary that i have seen all through
the philanthropic side
who cares so deeply about kids who's
motivated who's motivated
us to be better givers gary you're
you're the most amazing okay
i have this for you nothing's impossible
until the word itself is impossible
you're the these are your words okay and
then
the one i thought you'd really have this
and i'll send and give this to you when
i'm a person
i'm not a control freak but i can show
you the right way to do that
gary you remember the time you yelled at
me and you're like you're not gonna
[ __ ] walk out on here because you
care too much about those kids okay
i remember that moment very much because
i love you so much and i
i love that i love understanding people
and you know being on that board really
enabled me to flex in a different way
and i have and i also understand intent
it's one of my great luxuries that i was
gifted
my ability to understand intent is so
high and i know what your intent is
that's the truth and you called me out
from the beginning
okay and again even having made me wait
and you taught me the value
and you've given me unbelievable skills
and the partnership we have in life
that i hope goes on until your next 45
years birthday
can't wait for our 90th birthday love
you with my whole heart
i am proud proud to be your friend proud
to support you
and proud to shout your name out to the
world because of all the good you do
i love you for that thank you for being
here hope thank you so much continued
success
bye guys thank you hope
next up we've got from the tippy top
leadership at levi's
to american eagle to luxury and now a
wine pro
robert hanson
hey garyvee happy birthday guess what
i'm pouring to celebrate you
a little empathy white i love you for
that my friend it's it's
early and too early in california to be
drinking wine to celebrate your birthday
but i'm doing it anyway
there are very few people on earth that
i think and i think
this is a good time to say this because
i think some friends are coming here and
showing different angles of me that a
lot of you don't get to see so thank you
for the way
andrea all of you programmed this robert
is a
in a very small hand group of people who
i think cares more about the world than
himself
understands consumer behavior we we we
have
an incredible overlap of tendencies
and points of views and perspectives and
i i really adore you robert and thank
you for taking five minutes to say
what's up
well well likewise and i'm gonna take a
sip of the wine
[Music]
i figured it's uh what is it it's 12 22
in california
i'm starting happy hour early happy
birthday i couldn't be happier to be
here with and
uh with you than and then having this
opportunity
i you know given what you said i wanted
to say um
uh something that maybe others haven't
said i've been watching as much as i can
uh the thing that i've so enjoyed about
getting to know you man and we've known
each other for about seven years now
is you are so and i'll use your favorite
f-bomb [ __ ] incredibly competitive
you are like ruthlessly ambitious um
but you have this perfect balance of
being tough-minded and warm-hearted
and one of the things that i think is a
a
thought that is not used in business
enough is combining
competitiveness and ambition with love
and kindness
and people don't use those words often
enough
in business and i just wanted to share
with the group gary joined the
leadership conference
for cvi a couple weeks ago
and it was a two-day virtual conference
and i read all the results and kind of
the feedback the team had and the thing
that was the most resonant is the
discussion that you had with uh
my colleagues malika and jim because
that was what you discussed you
discussed being
ruthlessly competitive and ambitious and
being agile and innovative
and and driving as hard as hell to make
a difference in the world
but frankly doing it in the right way
and you know you you said it and i
appreciate it i believe we're here to
not only make business a source of
economic opportunity but a force for
positive change in the world and
that's why i love you back man i love it
i i can't uh how you doing
what what's uh you know had a good
meeting with nate and john today
getting our [ __ ] together so like that's
funny
um what are you seeing out there in the
wine and spirits business while we got
one minute just for fun since i was yeah
we're actually doing great and those
guys are doing great for all those who
don't know
um you know we acquired uh gary's
empathy wine brand with his found
co-founders john and nate and they're on
the team now and we're just doing
great things look i i think like every
other consumer category out there
there's a lot of action coming really
fast from highly innovative
new to world digitally native brands and
uh
you know the big companies are having to
play catch-up in terms of being
consumer first being much more agile and
innovative in their approach to building
consumer demand and
uh doing things that are just surprising
and delightful and
uh and what i love about working with
john and nate is it's the agility that
speed with which
you guys work and how we're bringing it
to a big uh cpg company like cbi
that's what's happening in terms of the
wine business uh you know the ever
elusive challenge for you mr wine of
file i mean it's a one funny story
before i get kicked out
i'll come to in a moment but what is
going to be the next section
yeah that turns on the category uh
yeah yeah you know the big growth of the
the chewy napa
you know cabs i want to hear the story
and i know we're at it so like
tell them one quick story when we were
trying to close the deal you may not
remember this is i i i know a lot of
whiner files but i don't know
a better one of file than the ceo of cbi
bill
newlands and he invited us to have
dinner at a restaurant close to his home
pre-covered
and gary walks in not only does he get
called out by some
random guy in winnetka illinois uh which
i found entertaining and you
you ate like two loaves of bread that
night i don't know
if you were nervous or what but
definitely not nervous
then you literally spun in circles
around that table kind of
wind up filing out with bill newlands
who's probably got one of the best wine
sellers i know of anybody in the
industry so
it was a very enjoyable experience for
me but you're an amazing guy
uh and i'm happy to spend more money
even more i really adore you thank you
brother
love you man take care have a good rest
of the event
thank you thank you it's fun
next up we've got some more
can we make this the marketing for now
all the time like this is fun
it's so easy to put together thank you
so easy
so next up we've got some more og vayner
faves they've got lots of stories
these guys are important so you got 10.
congratulations thank you met her
husband at vayner just saying
snail knows that game like more
marriages and
future babies hopefully
i haven't caught up with you in the
longest of all how are you what do you
got to share i'm dying
i'm so i'm curious
well you can see right behind me uh baby
bassinet
i have a seven week old daughter um
so that's been my life for the past few
months but
everything's good still doing
copywriting
as a freelancer and using the things
that you taught me
um enjoying the football season that's
all i'll say good to see you
great to see you happy birthday thank
you who's saying what do you got what's
a good story
like what i feel like you and i you you
and i have a
relationship in my heart you can
literally go anywhere here
yeah i think the story is other myself
our stories all three of our stories are
centered around uh
competition um and how much you love
competition
uh and so mine was uh so we went to
africa together the ghana for pencils of
promise right here is a big supporter so
a bunch of us from boehner
uh got to go to see uh you got to go to
a trip to africa to see some schools and
uh
one of the uh things you have to do on
that trip is to
see a school being built um so you see
some of the schools you meet some people
and you get to see school being built
and this is
like rural ghana um you know you're out
in
like a village essentially and you're
watching school being built and so what
they were doing was making bricks
um and so there was like this big metal
sort of a containers it was
blistering hot we'd spend days like on
this vw bus
um and we get there and i gotta learn
how to make a brick and so gary is like
i'm gonna make most [ __ ] brick like
gary it's not
no one's like trying to compete to make
the most breaks and he's like yeah we
are you all are everyone's competing to
make as many bricks as possible
and so there's like hundreds of people
just like making their breaks doing
their thing like milling around and then
there's
us from vayner just like hustling down
the thing like stamping bricks
um and it was like the most stressful
part of that entire trip and i remember
at the end of that uh we were all so
dripped in sweat right because we just
been making like hard bricks in the sun
and uh you had a shirt that said uh one
life on it
one of your gary shirts and there was a
random guy i don't think spoke
english when he saw your shirt and he
was like one life and these are yelling
one life
and you guys are yelling while i say
that for a while i mean gary you took
you literally took your shirt off and
gave it to the guy
um and then we have to go back in the
car with you like shirtless and funny
just like bricklaying experience but
that would never really kill me gary
competes all the time
oh man i love that it's such a good one
thank you that's what you got
hi gary happy birthday i love you
it's great to see you it's so great to
see you so happy to be here honored to
be here
um so yeah my competition story before
the gushy stuff
is it goes way back to the first year of
vaynermedia
so um a little little history
um i was the sixth employee of
vaynermedia i met gary at a conference
and made the best decision of my life to
join him in the founding team
and we had such a wild ride creating
what vaynermedia is today
and in that first year we kept it small
and tight we were honing our craft and
we had a really amazing crew and uh we
took a trip to vermont
together whole company and gary was
texting us the whole way up about all
the competition we were going to have
and we're already competing on what time
the cars arrive actually before you
yeah so the whole of the competition and
then the first
game we actually played was manhunt uh
throwback to everyone's childhood
and we're out there and teams playing
manhunt and then we're like hey we're
all away
in this beautiful place a bunch of us
were inside we're making dinner
having some drinks all of a sudden gary
comes in like
20 minutes after we're full on just
hanging out and no one else is playing
manhunt
in a pink polo gras-stained fists in the
air
i [ __ ] won nothing to push
well we're all hanging out don't forget
that manhunt
that just has always carried on through
as long as i've known you and i just
wanted to bring it back to that like
true
early day story um just so much hustle
so much heart
um and yeah i would love to hear ellis
too and then i'll get lucky
yeah i just want to uh share a story and
remind everyone that even if gary
isn't playing he still won't concede any
power
um because at our five-year vayner
reunion the first year that we went to
camp
we did a big team scavenger hunt and i
was a team captain
i was pumped up you know i was like all
right i'm gonna show gary like i can
motivate the team you know i'm getting
into my groove
and you know some of the teams were
competing some of the teams were
not enjoying um and i was like all right
team
sorry but we're doing all this we're
jumping in the pool we're running around
the lake we're
you know doing everything so we get to
the end we're the first
by far and i'm like yes i did it you
know and all the other teams kind of
come in and we settle in i'm telling
everyone that we won
and then gary you decided that you know
actually
it's not going to be the first team that
finished that wins
i'm gonna have everyone give speeches
about why they should win
and then i will decide and uh i i wish i
could remember
who but someone not me gave that
speech it still it still burns
it burns it burns um no but it was
it was a great experience and uh we had
fun doing it and it's
you know a thick a cloudy gary
experience of uh
a team domination while you still take
away
um a great experience lesson learned
vayner would not be where it is without
three of you and
so many other part of that crew and i
love you forever and cheer for you
forever
my gushy part is more in that vein is
just what a champion
uh you've always been for me and for
your people
and it's just really incredible um to
watch that unfold in all aspects of life
career uh wedding seeing your like
smiling face
uh in the zoo for a weird cove your
wedding just like forever cheering us on
will just mean everything
means everything will mean everything
forever um so thank you for that
and thank you for teaching me this super
valuable lesson
to make every decision with heart and
always from a place of love
i love you for that stuff thank you guys
thank you guys so much this really means
a lot to me it's
good to see you guys thanks guys happy
birthday
all right next up we've got badass cmo
become ceo 50 most daring
innovative and influential kristen
lemkow
you know what story i'm going to tell i
do i do i don't know if i want you to
tell it i'm going to try to side rail it
i love you you are such uh
gary i'm going to take you back to 2015
when i'll just set the context cmo of
jpmorgan chase for
about a year and i'm feeling pretty good
i'm on the forbes list i'm on the a
a board and i've got a budget in the
billion so
everyone wants to be my friend and if
you remember back then no one is good at
social and i'm going around
all these conferences and everyone says
well you've got to meet garyvee you've
got to meet garyvee and i'm like who's
garyvee and people went
you don't know garyvee so i do some
research
and i realized like you're the wine
library guy
and i grew up in short hills and i'm
like he's gonna love me
so i get to your people not you
and we set up a dinner and i get there
and i pick out a nice bottle of wine i
do some research because i know you're
the wine guy
and you show up late and i offer you a
glass of the wine and you say
i'm on a cleanse no food
no wine 45 minutes before you
leave convincing you about why i should
be a client
i was like well that was kind of strange
so do you remember what happened next
you called me the next day it was a
friday i was getting off the train i was
getting into my car
and you said i want to do business with
you
i run my business on relationships and
you are someone i want to do business
with
one of the great and that started a
five-year relationship
business relationship friendship
friendship and
that's really what i've learned from you
gary is
relationships matter and people
matter and who you do business with
particularly in this business
really really matters and it was one of
the best decisions i've ever made was to
become
business partners and friends with you
same and and you taught me about
relationships you didn't
need to learn that for me it is in your
essence
it really is i admire you so much i
couldn't recommend
i couldn't recommend this group and
again the people that follow me the most
you've heard this name
i couldn't recommend enough for people
to follow
and understand what this woman puts out
in the world she's head down now ceo
ceo in life so i don't know if she puts
out as much content as she used to but
that's what's good about the internet
internet it's out there and i think
um an incredible person to admire i
adore you for your love for the world we
spend more energy
talking about what we can do for the
society than we do about our friendship
about fun
and about work which is saying a lot
because we are busy and we talk a lot
about those things but
i really admire you and i i really i
really like you
you know that's just like a nice thing
to say to somebody i really like you
yeah well and you remember you had
turned down
a much bigger account with a competitor
or sort of friend of me
because off of one dinner a strange
dinner though it was
we clicked and we knew that we tried to
do cool stuff together and we have done
a lot
and and you've been incredibly helpful
to me even in my new job and will
continue to me and i'm so happy that
they
called me and asked me to do this thank
you for taking the time christine i hope
that you will be
a better dude partner friend
happy birthday you deserve all the love
on this call thank you so much you're so
sweet i can't wait to see you
peace out peace out thanks kristin
next up we've got daddy of four now
businessman extraordinaire
14 times mb all-star and 2009 world
series champion
alex rodriguez hey
rod what's good happy birthday my
brother how you doing man
i'm really well it's great to see your
face you look great
you look skinny you look younger you
look happy i am
i am it's you know you hear this kind of
stuff it means a lot to me man i
and i and i one of the great experiences
for me in the last half decade was
when you were making what i call a rod
3.0 happen
and and just what you're building and
just watching you move and getting into
some of those very early conversations
it's good to see you it's great to see
you one of my great memories was um
you know i have a kid that works in my
office and uh
he's first time in america and i said
gary i want to surprise one of my
young troops at a rock court but i went
to your home in the hamptons
you were there with your family your
brother your homies we sat down
and it was jennifer myself nadim
and we went there and you guys are
having a great time watching a little
football
and then meet you and jennifer have one
of the all-time greatest greatest talks
we've had in
in the last four or five years where we
started talking about what's next
i think that how the world is changing
how the opportunities become now we
never thought cover 19 would happen
but all he's done is expedited
everything but but we
we've been kind of planning for you know
garyvee 2.0 art corp 2.0 so
that was a fun fun night and we thank
you for that
thank you for saying that man how you
doing i'm doing great i'm doing great
i'm
i'm out here and uh how's your content
game how's your social media game like
how you feel about that part
going narrow to bring some value to
people what have you learned what's been
hard to sustain
what's been intriguing trying to bring
some value instead of just a love vest
which i enjoy but i would love to get
some
what what's been the hardest thing to
maintain because i think you
rightfully and i've talked to a lot of
big time people that were transitioning
into the new world
and i think you have the gusto to like
really do it
now that you've been doing it for a
little while what's been the hardest
thing to
maintain in this concept of content and
distribution and
and you know i'd love to curious what
you were going to say i really don't
know i'm curious
yeah so a few things in our portfolio
gary we have about
30 companies and they're broken up into
thirds
one third have struggled mightily a
third are flat and a third have never
done better
so overall the year has been kind of a
flat year for us um
but what has covit has presented for us
is an opportunity
to cut some of the fat and i don't mean
employees i mean efficiencies
um we we're growing like a bandit
we're hiring tons and tons of people
what we've done for example in our
health and wellness business
in our gyms down in south florida we had
boxes
real estate that we dreamed of having
that were not available for the last 10
years and now they
are so we're pouncing on them quickly we
have two gyms open
we're gonna build four more in the next
24 months and we want to get that
portfolio to about 15.
um the other part we've been doing is
around the clock is the launch of jlo
beauty
and we're going to launch e-commerce
coming up there'll be a big announcement
e-commerce and then we're going to do a
big announcement with one of the big
retailers
um around the corner and that's been
three years in the making
jennifer's worked so hard at this for
the last it's been something she's
wanted to do for 20 years
and i've never seen her work so hard and
commit to something
so she's on lane i think it's gonna be
i'm gonna send it for your family
i love it man i'm proud of you man i
really am i i love seeing this and i
can't wait to
watch you navigate for the next 50 in
this model keep going hard i
admire it thank you brother thank you
brother and uh happy birthday to you
thank you my man much love see thanks
next up we've got adweek's hottest
digital marketer
global executive extraordinaire seen in
a jets jersey on occasion
linda buff
not not too often in a jet stream more
giants more giants than steelers
so happy birthday my friend happy
birthday
before you go sweet and amazing
yesterday was one of my favorite things
i got to text you yesterday because we
had a business meeting that we didn't
know
and i had to text you in the middle of
it even a really important meeting
and honestly i swear to god it felt so
[ __ ] good
i just see you two days in a row as a
gift
and really yesterday literally to just
actually be in an actual business
meeting
together because we've been doing more
one-on-ones letting the teams do their
thing
it was just it felt so nostalgic and
like like i got to thank some others
here along the way your support um
wasn't was just enormous in the early
days of vayner it meant the world to me
your trust
in what was a new thing and
the partnership and and who you are as a
as a marketer and as a human um i just
admire you so much
well you think it's my birthday or
something because you're now telling my
story
so um when i was thinking about today
and thinking about
the long and really special relationship
we have
i went all the way back to south by
southwest at a party that i think pepsi
was throwing i think bonnen was
a party and i was there and you were on
stage
sort of doing your thing and i turned to
somebody and i said who is that
and josh carp said oh that's garyvee you
know garyvee i'm like oh
i felt like sheepish like no i don't
know him yet yeah and like
lem lemka who i heard a few minutes ago
i grew up in short hills
so when i heard wine library i'm like i
know wine library
and i remember leaving south by and
being
really intrigued but not knowing you and
we
sat down not long after that for
breakfast
and you know gary you had me at hello
and
in some ways like i've never looked back
i think you know this i bet on people
and you and the team you've built and
um what you've done for me personally
and for ge
nothing short of amazing so i have one
like little mini story
so early on in our sort of business
relationship
we did so many fun things i mean so many
fun things and we did this early little
experiment
called six second science and i remember
i said you know gary would really be
nice to win a camp lion we'd never want
to can lie in a ga
and you went ahead you submitted it lo
and behold
we went to cannes liar for a six
second vine video six second vine video
and i remember afterward you know i
think we did the the
campaign in january can obviously is in
is in june and i said gary like how did
you make this happen
and you said well you wanted to win so
it was important to win
and i think amongst the many many things
i love about you
and they're a lot your desire to win and
your competitive spirit
laced with kindness has to be like
number one in my book so
i love you so much i think i really wish
you the best
best best birthday year i love you so
much
hug everybody at home thank you for
that's such a great story thank you
thanks linda all right next up we've got
beloved by all
bad week 50 for seven years running
gun safety leader and great mama and
community leader
carolyn iverson
gary i literally emailed you
randomly today literally literally
literally this is real now
it is real it's totally wrong not
knowing that not knowing anything for
today what the format was or that you'd
be hearing i literally
emailed you four or five hours ago
randomly love you
yes you did and i it was the highlight
of the day because i really don't get
emails like that as you can imagine
it's like let me tell you about our
community standards at facebook love you
i was like yes okay first of all i look
i had
doug help me i have a fire real fire
going amazing
fireside chat i have wine from wine text
because of course in honor of you and i
just wanted to
i was first of all i'm so excited to be
part of this because i want
the world to know whoever is watching
what you mean to me and this is an
opportunity for
for me to share with you and i think
i've tried to in a few different ways
i'm going to take my glasses off because
i actually don't have to read which
means i barely can see you
but i want to say a few things to you
you first came into my life
interestingly enough when people ask me
about you and our relationship it looks
as if we've known each other
forever right that's the kind of bond
that we have and that's the kind of
warmth that you made me feel from the
moment
but we only met a handful of years ago
right i don't remember exactly what year
it was but it was not too
long ago and i remember meeting you and
i was sort of awestruck from the
beginning
because linda buff who was just on here
kristen
gail tiffard so many of my like
sisterhood girlfriends told me about you
told me about your brilliance
told me about your heart right your head
was clearly
amazing they knew you were
intellectually off the charts and knew
the the industry but it was your heart
and so when i had a chance to meet you i
was a little bit like hey i'm meeting
the star of garyvee
and you totally linda said you had her
at hello you had me at hello
you really really totally took me off my
feet because
of the passion that you bring and the
energy
and then what i didn't know at that time
i was like gary's like a really cool
industry guy well i have a lot of
industry people in my life
like i'm sure you do but they're not all
the type of people that i would
literally say are family
and that i would go to the map for to
the end of the earth and be there for
whenever you need it
[Music]
i'll forget what you did for my dad um
and if he were here he would be jumping
on this happy birthday to tell you
that the single greatest gift you ever
could have given a human being he had
been a jet fan since he was a toddler
and you showed up and had sam darnell
and chris martin
curtis martin excuse me come and visit
with him for his 80th birthday
and he i have never seen him happier or
more surprised or more touched
and that was after going to a jets game
together where he literally could not
stop talking about you and you
he followed you he was always interested
in the things that you were doing and
saying he wanted me to make sure that i
stayed very close to you that you are
going to be an important person for the
rest of my life
and so i so wish he was here to wish you
a happy birthday but
he's sending one from above and just
know what a difference you made in his
life and certainly in my life
and i also um thought a lot about
today's birthday you know message to you
and i really thought about getting my
mat back out my yoga mat
and i i went back and i looked at
exactly what i was wearing
i was wearing a pink shirt and leggings
and i was going to put that outfit on i
was going to lay down here
and just start and plank and just be
like gary i've been planking for like
two months where the hell have you been
because i had you
i had you and you twisted and played
with my mind
because i thought there was no chance no
chance you were gonna beat me
and what you showed was mental
resiliency at a whole
nother level and you freaking crushed me
in the end and i'm still pissed off
about it i haven't done really planks
since then so i've got to get back on
the game
um and i just i just want you to know
i adore the heck out of you i think that
there are so many
unbelievable qualities your parents have
raised
an extraordinary son they've raised an
extraordinary human
you are generous you are humble
you are kind you are all of the things
that i'm trying to instill in my girls
as i raise them because
honestly you exemplify all of that and
there's the gary that
many people know the public gary there's
also the gary
of just sitting with you one-on-one and
having you
look into a person's eye the way you
look into everyone's eyes when you're
talking to them
and they know that at that moment you
make them feel like they're the most
important people
on this planet and it's a gift you're a
gift
to me you're a gift to so many of your
friends your gift to your family
and i just wanted to tell you i love you
and so that's why
i'm here having a fireside birthday chat
with you with someone from my text
i love you gave me an excuse by the way
this is like before four o'clock and i'm
like
i have meetings after this and i'm like
i'm like why not
what the [ __ ] right it's why not i can
have a glass
anyway i'm loving you so very much thank
you thank you so much
that one got me all right
and last but not least a bestie
jets fan beyond family
and daddy of one of vayner's best
lugeneau
oh oh okay what's up my man
how are you how are you man thank you
brother tell him happy birthday brother
the business story tell him tell a story
tell something good
you know it this is hard in five minutes
to try it i've been thinking about this
whole week since
i talked to everybody and by the way
being the last year in this
group of people has been crazy to watch
but
you know i i guess i got to take it
right back to the beginning when we
first met each other you know
um i think it was right before
thanksgiving in 2002 it might have been
and gary had just joined wine library
and he was the hot kid
selling stuff and um my old company
said to me hey you got to go in and see
this guy and try to sell him something
so i i pounded gary for weeks for a
meeting and he finally gave me a meeting
you know i plugged in somewhere that was
a jet fan and one of my uh
messages to him so i go downstairs the
old wine library
if you remember gary the case is piled
to the ceiling
and i hear somebody yelling from the
other side where's that fake jet fan
where's that fake jetband
and it was just unbelievable how he
welcomed me in
that day talking about um you know
wanted to know my knowledge about the
jets which
actually got me i guess the next step
and
you know i got to know gary and and then
we went on a wine trip
out to napa and the classic
yeah our classic story of our
relationship i think from the beginning
um where we almost got destroyed out in
oakland watching a jet game
explain these people how i refuse to
take my jets jersey off
i didn't give a [ __ ] if somebody was
gonna stab me in that [ __ ] raiders
parking lot i'm not [ __ ]
i was wearing my [ __ ] i wasn't [ __ ]
and everybody i mean [ __ ] so i'll i'll
i'll tell everybody the story i'm a
little bit older than gary so
i think i had a little bit more sense uh
we finally
we take the lead we it's 10 10 at
halftime
um we're sitting in the 50-yard line
people are booing us yelling at us
remember what the guy told us and the
cop told us hey don't go to the bathroom
don't eat anything
so it's 10 10 i turn to gary and i'm
like listen man we got to take our
jerseys off
and gary's like no way i'm not taking it
off i'm tough this and that
i said listen man if we want to die for
this win this game we're dead
and if we lose this game we're dead so
the jerseys got to come off
so i convinced them to take the jersey
off um then when we were down 23 10 i
said let's get out of here
i'm not leaving i never leave a game to
the end and i convinced in the lead but
you know real quick on that too and then
on the way home and this i'll end it
with
i have two things to end with you know
on the way home gary and i are on the
plane
and now you all can imagine this this is
2003
january gary's got a yellow pad out and
he's he's mapping out for me
what he's going to do on the internet
and and
honestly you know we can sit here today
in 2020 and we all know the internet
this was 2003 a 7 8 year old internet
and this guy's telling me how he's going
to set up a tv studio and wine library
and he's going to start doing wine and
selling wine online
and you know i didn't doubt him i i
could tell how driven he was and what he
was going to do
you know and i think our relationship
grew from that um
from that day forward and you know and
the last thing you know what he's done
from
uh personally you know everybody knows
the gary that's the
i call him the superhuman on the
internet but the human that he is you
know
um he took my son lewis into in savannah
and
and and convinced me that um little lou
needed to work for him
um and screw school as he always says
and he took him under his wing and you
know i don't know that i can thank him
anymore for that any parent
um so i love you man for that and um
you know that's my heart brother my
heart thank you for being here
um too many stories and here it is there
he is
this is an outrageous group of people
here these two people here right now
um you know it's 3 55.
i think you need to go immediately
because there's a lot of things going on
in the world
and we need to get out of here but you
know i've got a big four o'clock right
that's it's the it's arguably the
biggest four o'clock
it's a big meeting it's a it's a fairly
big meeting
lou what do you think um hey
dad see you later
i love you man happy birthday brother
thank you brother
i'm going to start tagging you with og
i'll see you later i love you
just a quick story in my good luck yeah
we got a couple minutes
quick story um one of my earliest
memories
um of hanging out with gary when i was
maybe ten eight or six or seven eight
years old we went to pittsburgh
for the 2004 jets steelers playoff game
and i had known like i knew of gary like
my dad talked about him kind of sword or
whatever
and we've for some reason rented like a
minivan
and drove a winnebago yes we'd rather
winnebago
bespoke for that game because yeah more
rugged yeah
and uh and we drove and whatever and
gary made fun of me the whole way up
because i was a i was a packers fan
growing up because i loved brett favre
and uh
we went to the game and we were sitting
there and
doug bryant missed two field goals i
believe and just lost that game
and after the after the game i cried
and that gary always says that was the
moment i became a jets fan
um and i have very fond memories of that
entire trip
um not to mention the years that have
followed that have led to me working
here every single day
um i love you very much bro and uh you
remember the weird part of that game
lou and lou remember everybody came out
of the stadium devastating because we
were all split apart
and you're so happy this is an
interesting insight that i don't think
people understand me
dad you tell us this is your thing you
know it's just it's just so crazy with
gary we we sit at these games and he
bites his nails and he's a nervous wreck
and
he tells everybody how bad he wants to
win and then when we lose
he loves it because he wants to continue
that
that climb and eats it and i i kind of
i've kind of gotten that way too a
little bit like
but you know what after being a jeff fan
my whole life
i want i want that climb to start
getting a little bit close together
start eating a little bit better we got
to get to the right because i'm telling
you right now
just like a lot of the [ __ ] stories
here is a perfect way to end this
the things i showed you on that yellow
pad 17 years ago 18
years ago the things i told beth
comstock the things my mount ida friends
could say or brandon could say or
anybody else
when i tell the [ __ ] world i'm buying
the new york jets i tell the [ __ ]
world i'm buying the new york jets
let's go it's uh
it's let's get there it's been a journey
lou real quick two minutes because it's
something which lou
you keep doing okay you worked at vayner
for quite a while you came
into my world getting my admins been at
vayner you've been around me
what was the biggest aha when you
actually really went there
we talk about this a lot actually i know
exactly what it is um it's
someone said earlier i forgot who it was
the efficiency of the day
and how to actually take advantage of
every single day of every minute of
every single day we have your calendar
down
to 10 minute 15-minute increments during
the day i said i looked the other day
you had like 30 meetings one day it was
preposterous
and thinking about that people say like
oh yeah he's working all day he's so
busy blah blah and
the the vlog is good for that because
people can actually see that but being
in the mix of like actually getting
things done and also the fact that
things change 500 times
during the day like this meeting that
camp that's happening in two minutes
is a disgustingly important meeting and
it came together an hour ago
so like the the the amount of like speed
and
way you need to just move and make
things happen and doing things like
brand was saying just doing stuff
delta right because you thought you were
busy at vaynermedia people at
vaynermedia think they're busy but
there's just a different [ __ ] thing
going on andrew is busy
but like the way i'm playing this is
just [ __ ] ugly
it's gross so awesome
i didn't know you're a packers fan okay
it sounds like you got a meeting it's 3
59.
you got it out of here but only after i
say
happy birthday gary we love so much you
just
you just killed it every who knew you
could handle this many we now
we got down to increments of five
minutes a piece little lou what do you
think
yeah i mean your thing yeah wait till
it's two now now you set yourself up now
it's gonna be time bye everybody
one of your favorite guys i'm going to
wrap it up
thank you thank you bye everyone thank
you
thanks everybody for joining us this is
so fun we've got one more episode left
of marketing for the now
in 2020 it's on december 10th
from 12 to 2 p.m we've got 12 incredible
speakers
one question it's all around new year
predictions
and we've got speakers including the
shark
and founder of the corcoran group
barbara corcoran and
cmos from citibank general motors
land o'lakes microsoft netflix
salesforce and unilever and more to be
announced
hope to see you soon